[Musica]
forse il genere conta essere nati o
diventati donna o uomo conta o forse non
conta nulla
la prima volta che ho incontrato gli
occhi azzurri di adele è stato sulla
soglia di casa sua in via dei pettinari
qui a roma alcuni anni fa
in realtà servirebbe una serata parte
per raccontarvi l'intera vita di avere
l'infanzia a reggio calabria negli anni
trenta il traghetto giornaliero per
recarsi all'università di messina poiché
in quegli anni in tutta la calabria non
c'era una sola facoltà la laurea cum
laude in giurisprudenza è praticamente
immediato il diritto ad accedere la
carriera di magistrato eravamo prima del
63 in quanto donna e quindi cito
testualmente inadatta al giudizio e
all'equilibrio e soprattutto soggetta
alla capacità di commozione
ora per quel che vale spero non la
perderemo mai la capacità di commuoverci
e neanche di lottare per quello in cui
crediamo
adele infatti si trasferisce a roma
prosegue gli studi e diventa giornalista
una delle pochissime donne giornalista
alla fine degli anni cinquanta insieme a
camilla cederna e oriana fallaci scrive
lavora va caccia di incarichi e notizie
tollera l'obbligo di firmare con
pseudonimo maschile i primi articoli
riceve vagonate di querele e affronta
cause diffamatorie e diffamanti
vincendole sempre le dimissioni per
solidarietà a colleghi licenziati
ingiustamente sono tante ei
licenziamenti subiti per aver scritto
articoli scomodi o aver rifiutato le
avance del direttore di turno
altrettanti la carriera di adele
attraverso le più importanti testate
giornalistiche italiane va dagli anni 60
fino al 2015
praticamente l'altro ieri per avere
un'idea della vita rocambolesca che ha
avuto other e vi invito a leggere uno
dei suoi libri più belli e ironici una
quasi biografia lavorativa dal titolo 9
dimissioni e mezzo che dettaglia con
lucidità
indubbiamente ironia e maestria ogni
fatica incontrata ogni battaglia vinta o
persa e il prezzo alto che avere una
deontologia professionale richiede adele
cambria non è rinomata come altre
giornaliste del suo tempo sono convinta
che fra voi qualcuno l'ha sentita
nominare stasera per la prima volta è
stata una donna che non ha fatto
scalpore non ha spintonato per fare
carriera non ha fatto le scarpe a
nessuno è stata sobria di una sobrietà
elegante e paziente vorrei poterla
definire donna d'altri tempi ma sarebbe
il più grave torto che potrei farle
poiché nessuna più di lei ha saputo
essere contemporanea contemporaneo è
colui o colei che appartiene vive e
opera
nell'età presente adele infatti è stata
madre quando essere madre significava
necessariamente smettere di lavorare ed
è stata lavoratrice quando lavorare
significava necessariamente trascurare i
figli e fatah moglie ed ex moglie è
stata femminista quando il diritto
all'autodeterminazione della donna non
era nemmeno preso in considerazione è
stata direttrice responsabile del
quotidiano lotta continua
negli anni 70 è stata co fondatrice
della casa internazionale delle donne di
roma co fondatrice del teatro la
maddalena è stata parte della redazione
della rivista f prima rivista femminista
ha recitato in due film
di pasolini e fatah autrice di 14 libri
e centinaia di interviste
questa era del e sempre sul pezzo e
contemporanea
quando era incinta di mia figlia ho
trascorso l'estate a roma a casa di
adele per lavorare insieme all editing
di un libro la mattina mi alzavo e adele
ovviamente era già sveglia era già stata
in edicola
passando dalla scala di servizio per non
rischiare di svegliarmi e aveva
acquistato i tre quotidiani che
giornalmente acquistava la repubblica il
messaggero e l'unità li aveva già letti
sottolineato a matita parole passaggi
importanti e li aveva montichiari sulla
catasta di riviste dei giorni precedenti
la trovavo in salotto con la radiolina
accesa infilata nella vestaglia che
ascoltava la rassegna stampa bevendo una
tazzina di caffè sorrideva e mi diceva
buongiorno care a me alla pancia ora
mettiamoci al lavoro
il ricordo che ho di quell estate romana
è fatta di gelati al limone e risate di
adele e ora che adele non c'è più mi
manca soprattutto mi manca la sua
capacità di essere contemporanea e umana
credo sia questa per me la direzione da
seguire contemporanei e umani e
l'insegnamento di adele gli stigmi da
smantellare
oggi può darsi non siano gli stessi di
quando lei era una giovane donna ma sono
convinta che se non affrontiamo ora ciò
che ci fa paura
queste angosce diventeranno inviolabili
e furbescamente già stanno cambiando
nome bisessuale
inter sessuale transgender uscendo dalla
questione di genere schizofrenico
musulmano carcerato e ancora
femminicidio gender pay gap ius soli
diritto di voto agli stranieri che così
tanto stranieri poi forse non sono
inclusione di persone disabili in un
mondo fatto su misura per chi ama
definirsi normale e poi tanto normale
forse non è educazione di genere a
scuola e riconoscimento sostanziale di
tutte le confessioni religiose anche nel
mondo del lavoro
ho avuto l'occasione di conoscere
un'azienda toscana che ha fatto una
scelta decisamente inclusiva e
innovativa ha scelto di lasciare a casa
nella giornata del venerdì
i propri dipendenti musulmani venerdì
giornata di festività islamica e di
chiedere a loro la possibilità di
lavorare la domenica
questo ha fatto sì che l'azienda
restasse aperta un giorno in più quindi
7 giorni su 7
poiché i dipendenti musulmani coprivano
il turno domenicale è stato un lampante
vantaggio per tutti azienda dipendenti
clienti fatturato
questo per dirvi che la diversità porta
anche ricchezza
mi permetto di aprire questo argomento
perché mi occupo di includere le
diversità nel mondo delle aziende e le
aziende sono mondi e mondi influenti che
possono spostare l'ago della bilancia
nelle scelte globali possono ad esempio
concedere un congedo di paternità più
lungo di quello accordato dall'attuale
legislazione e possono addirittura
concederlo a una famiglia formata da due
papà possono e devono abbattere le
barriere architettoniche per includere
diversità nel luogo del lavoro possono
avvicinare culture distanti e talvolta
antagonista
per farle lavorare insieme su un
obiettivo comune
del resto esiste un solo colore di pelle
tollerabile
un'abilità più normale delle altre non
credo più giusto in un altro un amore
che ho appassionato di un altro e
soprattutto ha senso porsi queste
domande quando gli individui sul pianeta
sono 7 miliardi e mezzo e ciascuno a ma
a modo proprio le lingue sono quasi
7mila le lingue parlate sono quasi
settemila ci sono alfabeti informati da
74 lettere e alfabeti formati solo da
undici lettere eppure comunichiamo le
sfumature della pelle umana possono
variare da completamente nero a incolore
con tutto il ventaglio che ci sta nel
mezzo
ho letto un articolo una volta che
elencava i 46 modi che esistono per
sorseggiare un caffè italiano ovviamente
l'articolo ho scoperto che sul pianeta
ci sono 140mila varietà di riso e a
proposito di riso non troverete due
persone che scoppiano a ridere allo
stesso modo
we fly team è una pattuglia aerea civile
italiana ed è l'unica al mondo in cui
due dei tre piloti sono disabili
alessandro paleri leader con oltre 2.000
ore di volo all'attivo e tetraplegico e
marco cherubini gregario di sinistra con
1.800 ore di volo all'attivo è
paraplegico entrambi non possiedono
l'uso delle gambe
eppure volano pilotano i loro aerei
ultraleggeri con dei comandi ideati e
realizzati dallo stesso alessandro che
fra l'altro è anche l'ingegnere
aerospaziale e allora gettiamo lo
sguardo avanti e immaginiamo nuove
possibilità manca poco a che il primo
disabile possa gravitare
spazio o un cinese diventare sindaco di
prato o una donna presidente degli stati
uniti e manca poco perché si smetta
finalmente di dire un bambino che piange
non fare la femminuccia e che possa
ricevere una cucinetta in regalo
se questo il suo desiderio manca poco
per avere infermieri di colore negli
ospedali e non solo nelle serie tv e
perché le donne chirurgo che diventano
primario superino all'attuale indegna
soglia dell'un per cento
manca poco al mondo del futuro in cui la
percezione di diverso sempre più sfocata
finirà per dissolversi del tutto in una
contemporaneità nuova fatta di
condivisione e relazioni oggi siamo
tutte e tutti adele lo siamo quando non
ci fermiamo davanti a un no quando
scaviamo alla ricerca di una risposta
e quando non ci fermiamo davanti al
fatto di essere donna uomo trans gay
anziano malato disabile musulmano ebreo
la strada l'unica per l'evoluzione
dell'umanità e lasciarle interagire
queste differenze vitali inaspettate ma
gli insopprimibili differenze che
costituiscono il nostro essere unici e
uniche grazie
[Applauso]